une nouvelle étude vient confirmer
encore une fois qu'il n'ya aucun lien
entre les troubles du spectre autistique
et le vaccin de la rougeole la rubéole
et les oreillons leurs aires où c'était
une publiée dans le journal de
l'association médicale américaine et
possiblement l'étude définitive sur
cette question très controversée
on a examiné près de cent mille enfants
dont plusieurs étaient considérés à
risque michel bonsoir on soit en se
disant que c'est une nouvelle étude qui
devrait rassurer les parents qu'est ce
qu'elle dit au juste bon on espère que
ça va rassurer en fait il ya une
douzaine d'autres qui disait la même
chose auparavant mais cette usine chose
de plus c'est leur rôle de l'hérédité un
frère et une soeur qui ont la maladie
augmente le risque de la voir regardons
ensemble
alors quand je parle effectivement des
troubles du spectre autistique le céline
j'ai inclus l'autisme également le
syndrome d'asperger les troubles
envahissants du développement non
spécifique alors la cohorte était
immense on le dit là près de cent mille
enfants qui avaient offert ou une soeur
et on a on a regardé les chiffres 1 %
d'entre eux souffrent de l'autisme et 2
% ont un frère ou une soeur qui
souffrent de l'autisme maintenant on est
à lire regarder à l'intérieur de ça et
là on est vu que ceux qui ont frère ou
une soeur avec de l'autisme avait 7 % de
chance de l'avoir
et ceux qui n'avaient des frais on sort
100 l'autisme avait 1 % les chansons on
voit que l'hérédité joue un rôle
alors là on est allé voir ceux qui ont
été vaccinés vers ceux qui n'ont pas été
vaccinés 84% été vaccinées 16 % n'ont
pas été vaccinés et on est arrivés aux
mêmes chiffres
donc on conclut que le vaccin n'a rien à
voir avec le tisme haineux module même
pas l'hérédité
donc on parle de deux choses vraiment
séparés qui ont pallié bon après c'est
important de rappeler d'où vient cette
controverse parce qu'elle est très
tenace en fait c'était une étude mais a
été publiée dans le magazine ou est très
réputé ctc de 27 ans 98 dr wakefield qui
avait falsifié littéralement à ces
résultats
maintenant il avoué on a retiré la
publication on se met tant qui a été
payé pour faire ça donc
face à ce mauvais coup là on se retrouve
avec des parents
qui malheureusement continuent à ne plus
croire aux vaccins cette menace parce
que récemment tout récemment il y avait
cette épidémie de rougeole est encore là
on voyait des parents qui étaient très
très réticents à faire vacciner
seulement on a faim chronique ensemble
là dessus c'est à disneyland en
californie
quelques centaines de cas au canada et
aux états-unis au québec et encore une
fois il faut rappeler que la rougeole
c'est mortel près de deux millions six
cent mille personnes ne sont morts
annuellement de la rougeole avant le
vaccin pour un total de plus de 200
millions personnes qui sont décédées de
cette maladie là depuis le milieu du 19e
siècle
donc c'est une maladie qui ne faut pas
prendre à la légère la rougeole
d'où l'importance de se faire vacciner
on verra si cette étude va réussir à
rassurer donc les parents une fois pour
toutes on verra bien merci beaucoup
merci cd